je vous présente mais vous le connaissez
le député du Bas-Rhin porte-parole du
groupe Renaissance Charles Gislaine
Souls merci bonsoir et merci à vous
d'avoir accepté avec Mathilde panot de
débattre ensemble avec un sujet très
important qui est arrivé aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée et qui est l'avenir de la
filière nucléaire c'est à VOUS
absolument donc on est depuis cet
après-midi sur l'examen du texte
nucléaire et j'étais présent en
hémicycle et donc j'ai eu l'occasion
d'entendre les propos et maintenant de
votre groupe et je suis en fait assez
surpris d'entendre que votre groupe va
s'opposer à ce texte puisque la filière
nucléaire est une filière historique
d'excellence de la France c'est une
grande aventure collective à la fois
scientifique et surtout industrielle moi
j'avais toujours cru comprendre que que
la gauche était attachée à l'industrie
et donc c'est assez contradictoire
j'aimerais que vous nous expliquer
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes opposé à
cette relance du nucléaire voulue par le
président de la République alors déjà ne
soyez pas surpris c'était dans notre
programme présidentiel nous nous sommes
effectivement pour la sortie tonifier du
nucléaire il s'agit pas du jour au
lendemain d'arrêter mais parce que alors
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que
c'est aujourd'hui ce qui empêche le
développement des énergies renouvelables
quand vous devez mettre 100 milliards
dans le grand carénage pour pouvoir
prolonger les centrales en construire
d'autres et bien c'est autant d'argent
que vous ne mettez pas dans le
développement des énergies renouvelables
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
un problème de résilience de l'énergie
nucléaire je parle évidemment des
refroidissements des réacteurs et on est
en sécheresse hivernale donc la question
du refroidissement quand parfois il est
arrivé en période de sécheresse que la
moitié des réacteurs soit à l'arrêt soit
pour des questions de maintenance soit
pour des questions justement de
refroidissement et puis pour des
questions géopolitiques regardez que là
on est en train d'importer de Russie ça
doit quand même nous poser des questions
là-dessus par ailleurs nous n'avons pas
d'uranium dans notre pays donc ça pose
un problème de souveraineté la troisième
chose et qui est très importante pour
moi vous savez moi je suis
sous-traitante d'une association
marraine pardon d'une association de
sous-traitants nucléaire donc la
question de l'emploi et des conditions
d'emploi dans le nucléaire m'intéressent
beaucoup il se trouve que 80% de la
maintenance nucléaire est faite
aujourd'hui par des sous-traitants dans
des conditions de travail qui sont
vraiment très mauvaises avec des gens
qui n'ont pas le statut et je le dis
nous avons sur cette question un gros
problème sur l'excellence dont vous
parlez parce que nous sommes en train de
perdre avec cette sous-traitance la
connaissance des réacteurs quant aux
scandale Creusot forge ça vous dit
quelque chose donc moi je veux qu'on
développe une des filières d'énergie
renouvelables d'excellence et que on
arrête petit à petit avec une énergie
qui est plus cher que les énergies
renouvelables qui est dangereuse qui
produit des déchets dont on ne sait que
faire et qui est surtout non résiliente
aux aléas climatiques ce qu'il faut
faire et ce que la France a commencé à
faire d'ailleurs d'autres pays le font
c'est les deux en réalité c'est d'avoir
le nucléaire et c'est de développer
davantage les énergies renouvelables on
a voté une loi il y a quelques semaines
d'ailleurs vous vous y êtes aussi
opposés ces contradictoires
la filière la filière nucléaire
française ne va pas bien depuis
plusieurs années mais pourquoi
parce que on a détourné nos plus
brillants esprits de cette filière là
par un matraquage médiatique par un
lobbying intensif de vos amis
écologistes et aussi d'un certain nombre
de personnes qui sont qui sont proches
de la France insoumise et qu'on a
dégouté des jeunes françaises et des
jeunes Français de s'engager dans cette
filière heureusement cette filière elle
est résilience elle se relance et elle
fait la fierté et surtout elle fait
l'indépendance énergétique du pays donc
votre discours est contradictoire et
surtout totalement hors sol d'une
certaine façon parce qu'on aura toujours
besoin d'énergie on aura toujours besoin
d'électricité et que notamment le parc
automobile sera c'est un fait de plus en
plus électrique donc les besoins
d'électricité seront croissants de notre
pays vous voyez en fait en fait la
différence entre vous et moi c'est que
il y a toujours des questions de court
terme vous ne voyez les choses qu'à
court terme et je vais vous dire
pourquoi c'est pas possible de faire les
deux quand je vous dis 100 milliards
quand vous regardez le fiasco de l'EPR
vous allez nous expliquer que les EPR 2
dont la technologie n'est toujours pas
avec un EPR qui est absolument
dramatique en termes de bilan il devait
coûter 3,3 milliards il en coûtera au
moins 21 milliards il y a un problème
avec la cuve il y a un problème avec le
couvercle il y a un problème avec les
soudures Bouygues a été condamné pour
travailler dissimulé avec 150
travailleurs et je pourrais continuer à
si longtemps les plans de l'EPR sont
dans la nature ça ça a été révélé par
Greenpeace c'est quand même absolument
incroyable ça n'a inquiété personne vous
voyez sur ces plans notamment la taille
des boulons de portail qui entoure le Pr
donc vous vous m'expliquez qu'avec une
technologie EPR 2 qui n'est pas prête
une technologie SMR vous savez les
petits réacteurs qui auraient qui n'est
pas prête vous allez m'expliquer que
c'est comme ça qu'on va faire face à la
fois au défi énergétique alors que alors
que cette question la technologie qui
n'est pas prête c'est intéressant c'est
pas vrai en fait ce que ce que ce que
vous dites parce que le Pr on sait le
faire
le Pr on sait le faire et il en existe
un en Chine à tiehan qui a été fait par
EDF et la vraie question la vraie la
vraie question sur le Pr c'est pourquoi
est-ce que ce chantier est en réalité je
suis d'accord a été une sorte de fiasco
que nous avons connue pour celui pour
celui de flamants ville et ce qui a été
notamment mis en avant par le rapport
folle s'il y a quelques années c'est que
cette filière nucléaire en France est
affaissée pendant plusieurs années qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de manquements que ça
soit chez EDF et que nous avons repris
les choses en main il va pas échapper
que la direction de DF a été échangée
que l'État a tapé du point sur la table
et que donc cette filière il faut la
soutenir et moi je trouve dommage que
dans le débat que nous avons cette
semaine sur le nucléaire vous n'ayez pas
donné le signal de vouloir soutenir
cette vidéo quand je vous donne des
arguments enfin excusez-moi mais on a
des arguments en fait la question de la
sécheresse et de l'eau est un argument
la question du coup avec un nucléaire
qui est plus cher que les énergies
renouvelables est un argument la
question des déchets que vous voulez
enfuir dans La Mure d'énergie neuronale
je crois que c'était la proposition de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne sait pas faire si
on sait faire en fait c'est impossible
si il y a un pays il y a un pays qui a
essayé mais il y a des choses à faire
sur le stockage mais par ailleurs vous
avez des énergies il y a un pays qui a
essayé et moi je trouve que je le
connais très bien puisqu'il est
frontalié de ma circonscription c'est
l'Allemagne a essayé c'est un la
politique énergétique allemande est un
naufrage depuis 10 ans et ils ont que
nous allons expliquer du nucléaire pour
des raisons de craint dogmatique après
Fukushima bilan vous avez aujourd'hui un
gouvernement à moitié écologiste qui
rouvre du charbon et vous importez du
gaz de schiste et vous voulez me faire
croire que c'est différent chez nous
dans
plus d'énergie renouvelable que nous
donc à un moment soit ils l'ont remplacé
par des énergies carbonées c'est un
naufrage c'est un naufrage j'avais
importé du gaz de chez américain oui ou
non oui vous avez réouvert une centrale
à charbon oui ou non oui temporairement
oui
dans les mêmes si on ne met pas de
l'argent à la fois dans la formation de
toutes celles et ceux dont on a besoin
pour les énergies renouvelables ce texte
d'ailleurs mais non mais
j'ai lu tous les articles c'est un des
objectifs du test que nous allons c'est
de faire en sorte que on aille en marche
forcée sur le nucléaire avec aucun
retour en arrière possible et aucun
question démocratique derrière et en
plus de ça vous mettez un coin dans la
sûreté nucléaire en demandant à l'irsm
de fusionner avec la SN donc vraiment ce
texte enfin n'a rien à voir avec ce film
à l'heure du dé climatique
mon second sujet plus territorial et là
je voulais plus savoir un échange pour
un peu connaître votre votre sentiment
puisque il y a eu il y a quelques jours
le rapport annuel de la Cour des comptes
et ce qui a vraiment été très mis en
avant dans ce rapport sur la
décentralisation c'est le naufrage
complet de la réforme des grandes
régions alors moi étant alsacien vous
comprendrez que ce sujet me touche
beaucoup puisque il y a eu cette
incompréhension de la disparition de
l'Alsace et de la création de cette
structure voilà très abstraite quel
grand est ce que vous vous êtes plutôt
ouverte à ce qui est des corrections
voilà de ces méga méga region c'est une
atteinte qu'on soit en cas de coins du
pays alors nous on est même plus que
pour des corrections on est au départ
pour une constituante c'est à dire que
le peuple réécrive la constitution et la
question de la démocratie aux différents
échelons bon évidemment nous on attache
beaucoup d'importance à la commune et je
rappelle je le dis en passant que 50%
des mers ruraux sont des retraités dans
ce pays donc si on repousse l'âge de
départ ça va poser des soucis mais bon
je mets ça de côté on est très sachez
évidemment à la commune au département
et évidemment on a ces méga régions qui
arrivent et qui posent un problème de
lien démocratique du citoyen avec avec
la région ce sur quoi nous sommes
d'accord moi je pense que la question
des régions elle doit aussi correspondre
à des réalités physiques on avait une
idée pendant la présidentielle après
c'est d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes en
parle sur le problème des bassins
versants de l'eau mais on avait émis une
idée bon c'est une idée à discuter qui
était de dire pourquoi pas faire
correspondre à des bassins versants des
régions qui en quelque sorte permettrait
de donner
la question sur le cycle de l'eau mais
qui permettrait de donner une unité à la
politique de l'eau comme on sait que par
exemple l'eau va être un des grands
problèmes du 21e siècle on peut par
exemple revenir sur des choses voilà
l'Alsace par exemple ça aurait du sens
avec
voilà non mais par exemple ça aurait du
sens avec ça mais qui permet de redonner
à partir de grands enjeux qu'on a enfin
voilà qu'on a affronté de redonner une
cohérence à ce qu'est la région et qui
ne soit pas à quelque chose de
complètement déconnecté et dimanche dans
lequel évidemment le citoyen ne s'y
retrouve pas et donc je trouve que cette
réponse elle est elle est intéressante
et puis dans le cas l'Alsace qui
m'intéresse au premier chef
effectivement comme je le disais bon on
est traversé par des plus grands fleuves
d'Europe qui est le rein et il y a il
faut faire déstocker Christophe Béchu
annoncera peut-être des choses là-dessus
dans quelques jours et puis il y a
surtout l'une des plus grandes nappes
phréatiques d'Europe donc un point de
vue de l'eau ça fait sens et puis je
crois surtout ce qui est important avec
les régions et ça d'ailleurs été écrit
noir sur blanc par la Cour des comptes
c'est je pense quelque chose de très
important que une région a besoin d'une
cohérence historique et politique voilà
et c'est sûrement ce qui manquait dans
un certain nombre de ces nouvelles
grandes régions et que donc dans le cas
par exemple du grand test il y avait
absolument aucune cohérence politique à
historique à se découpage alors que la
région Alsace elle a une longue histoire
avait une longue histoire et une
cohérence et donc nous on est plusieurs
députés à porter le retour voilà de
cette région Alsace on verra ce qu'il
admirera dans la fameuse commission
transpartisane et vous êtes favorable à
un retour à la situation antérieure de
découpage
je pense pas parce que par exemple il
faut par exemple dans le cas de la
Normandie et que je voudrais courant qui
a été fait c'est-à-dire les deux
Normandie ont été réunifiés il y a
aucune attente à ce qu'on refasse la
basse et la Haute-Normandie par exemple
dans le cas du grand test on voit très
bien que cette région ça n'a pas pris
auprès de la population et que il y a
surtout ce territoire l'Alsace qui est
quand même pas un territoire neutre dans
l'histoire de France qui s'est senti
vraiment pris de front et il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de cohérence voilà
géographique et historique et donc nous
allons travailler à son retour et pour
aller un petit peu au-delà ou plus dans
le détail est-ce qu'il y a un échelon
territorial que vous voudriez supprimer
ce qu'il y en a trop
oui bah par exemple un échange
territorial qui nous semblerait
intéressant de supprimer tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui par exemple moi je vis dans
un territoire dans lequel il y a des EPT
donc des établissements publics
territoriaux donc vous êtes dans une
sorte de territoire alors moi ça
s'appelle le pt12 vous avez le PT 11
personne ne sait qu'il est dans ce
territoire vous n'avez pas d'élection
directe donc les gens n'ont absolument
aucune conscience vraiment en fait ça ça
pose des problèmes c'est des échelons en
fait qui sont mis
intermédiaires et je trouve que c'est
des problèmes de démocratie et de
cohérence pour les pour les citoyens qui
sont quand même le nombre de communes
vous nez touchez pas ensuite
les départements tout ça se combinent
avec les grandes régions tout ça vous
semble cohérent ben nous les grandes
régions on n'est pas trop pour c'est ce
que je vous explique à l'instant mais en
fait la question c'est de pas faire des
juste des ajustements sur des choses à
un moment il faut qu'on revoit comment
et organiser le territoire et du coup la
démocratie aux différentes échelles et
comment elle se répondent et nous par
exemple dans l'idée de planification
écologique d'avoir de se rendre maître
du temps il y a l'idée d'avoir bon
quelque chose de planification avec des
objectifs nationaux qui sont donnés et
ensuite que par commune avec les
syndicats avec les associations et puis
s'il y avait un déclinaison de ce qu'on
peut faire à chacun des échelons et je
trouve qu'en terme de démocratie c'est
intéressant rapidement pour conclure sur
le cas de l'Alsace en fait on a notre
projet est un projet de simplification
et de proximité parce que les deux
Conseils départementaux ont été réunis
il y a deux ans donc il n'y a plus
qu'une collectivité européenne à
l'échelle de l'Alsace qui en fait elle
est compétences d'un département et donc
l'idée ce serait d'absorber les
compétences régionales et d'avoir une
collectivité unique à l'échelle de
l'Alsace qui a les fois les compétences
de la région et du département et donc
on fait sauter un strate une strate et
donc c'est de la simplification pour les
élus locaux qui travaillent au jour le
jour et puis surtout plus de proximité
pour les concitoyens travaux chantiers
merci beaucoup
le millefeuille merci beaucoup